well that was initially a year ago a
video suggesting people use yellow vests
as a symbol of dissent against French
fuel taxes now together with his
original Julie Joan the man who came up
with the idea
yellow vests marked the fuel protests
but were then adopted as the symbol of
popular anger against the French
government every car in France another
yellow vest his link utad guessed it
could become the symbol of protest he
recorded a video and his phone and then
saw it being watched again and again
ding-ding-ding if you guessed wrong more
than 5 million views so far if my little
piece of yellow fabric is enough to
bring change about in France I would be
more than proud I hope we achieve it
this wasn't the protest have pushed
concessions from President macron yoku
Dollard is not satisfied he wants more
change more respect for the jewish-owned
protesters we're constantly attacked
even by the police who always shout at
us to go and get a job always accusing
us of being lazy frustrating but
profound the jala zone movement has
shaken France over the past year but the
movement he started has been doubled
with controversy and pain many have been
injured in clashes between police and
protesters recently the numbers joining
the protests have fallen on Thursday
France is facing a huge day of
industrial action from trade unions and
julie joan combined for some it's a
crucial test of whether the yellow vests
will persevere thursday is either a new
beginning or it's the end we've seen
many people injured and people are tired
every week we lose more and more numbers
though down the road in montpellier
trade unionists are preparing thursday
strike will hobble many services
particularly france's transport network
a protest against president macrons
economic reform plan there will be demos
but more importantly there will be the
call to strike people must strike and we
must paralyze the economy this will be
the biggest day of industrial action
that France has seen for decades this
nation is bracing itself Adam Parsons
Sky News Montpellier